I just want you to take the time to
think back the last time you ate because
you felt truly hungry the last time you
ate so much you felt absolutely stuffed
how did you feel afterwards did you feel
satisfied or were you annoyed with
yourself and felt guilty you know eating
too much every once in a while is normal
I tend to do that as well especially
over the festive season however if you
feel that your eating habit is out of
control if you tend to think about food
all the time and feel guilty depressed
or ashamed after eating then watch this
video through I want you to first
understand the seven different kinds of
hunger how you can stop overeating and
learn to eat more mindfully so eating
more mindfully is basically expanding
our awareness around food habits so that
we can start to make a more conscious
decision of what we put into our mouths
and when so the first kind of hunger is
physical hunger this is the real kind of
hunger you can physically feel hungry
your stomach is growling your blood
sugar level is low your energy is low
and you find it tough to concentrate on
the task you're doing this is when your
body truly needs food and you should be
eating so what I want you to do is start
listening to your body's physical cue
eat when you feel moderately hungry
don't leave it until when you feel
extremely hungry this can often lead to
making bad food choices and eating too
much of food in one sitting
hence lead to weight gain as well the
second kind of hunger is nutritional
hunger if you're someone that says I
just feel hungry all the time and I can
just eat and eat and eat well chances
are you might be feeding your body with
crappy foods foods which are very high
in calories but low in nutrients yes
they will keep you satisfied but only
for a very short period of time after 30
minutes to an hour you will start to
feel packaged again that is because our
body naturally craves for nutrients and
roof
so your brain will tell you to eat and
eat but instead of consuming a
nutrient-dense meal you ended up eating
more crappy food consume more calories
than what your body needs and still
don't feel satisfied so it is a vicious
cycle eat crappy food don't get the
nutrients your body need don't feel
satisfied and eat more crappy food and
so on and suddenly whoa where did that
extra weight come from so if you fall
under this category it is really simple
I want you to start to eat real foods
foods which are minimally processed you
will find that you will feel satisfied
and you will have the cravings to eat
more food and you will naturally start
to lose weight so if you're interested
to learn more about nutrition healthy
living and fitness you can do so by
signing up to the National Academy of
Sports Medicine & ASM online personal
training course they are currently
offering a 14-day free trial so you can
learn more about the fundamental foods
that our body needs ways to becoming a
personal trainer and also to understand
your clients so be sure to click on the
link in my description box and get more
information
the next hunger is emotional a hot
hunger we live in a culture where we
turn to food to fix everything we
associate food to happiness and comfort
so when we view the opposite emotions
such as stress anger sad loneliness or
boredom we tend to turn to food to try
to fix our emotions so instead of
dealing with the deeper issue we want
instant gratification because we want to
feel better this is also similar to how
some people might turn to alcohol or
drugs yes it will fix you but only for a
very short period of time when that's
over I can assure you you will feel
worse and hit yourself for binge eating
so it is very important to identify that
emotional hunger isn't located in the
stomach
you don't feel physically hungry it
often craves for specific comfort food
for instance you might want to have ice
cream or chocolate to satisfy your
emotion
and it often leads to - eating so
instead of having few pieces of
chocolate or few scoops of ice cream you
ended up eating the entire block of
chocolate and the entire ice cream top
and you don't feel satisfied even when
you're full and this often leads to
regret guilt or shame if this issue the
next time you have the urge to - eat put
the foot down take three deep breaths
and ask yourself what am I asking the
food to do for me if it is linked to an
emotional trigger don't reject the
emotion but bring awareness to your
feelings and you might be able to find
other ways to help to deal with them for
instance if you are feeling lonely or
feeling down
speak to a friend or read a
self-development book that might help
you through your issues if you are
feeling really tired then take the time
to relax take a nice warm bath or treat
yourself to a nice cup of hot chocolate
if you're just feeling bored then read a
book watch a film or just go for a nice
long walk so shift your thinking away
from food and change the action to feed
your emotion not your body the next kind
of hunger is habit hunger this is me so
breakfast at 8:00 a.m. lunch at 1:00
p.m. and dinner at 7:00 p.m. we eat at
specific times because we train our body
to do so and there is nothing wrong with
this in fact it can be a good eating
habit and prevent overeating
however habit hunger can be an issue if
we tend to associate food to a certain
activity for instance do you get a snack
when you go to the movies or watch TV
well let's face it chances are you are
not hungry and you don't really need to
munch you develop this habit over time
so if you fall into this category I want
you to start breaking the habit and keep
your hands busy with something else for
instance instead of punching away try to
have a cup of hot tea or keep your hands
busy by knitting or sewing next hormonal
hunger lady
you know very well what I'm talking
about so you've been doing so well in
your eating patterns and few days
leading up to your period your hormone
changes and suddenly you crave for all
the bad fruits well you don't have to
deprive yourself but what is important
is that you're aware of the changes that
are happening to your body so indulge in
a mindful way and really enjoy the food
you will feel satisfied with less and
you will be in control of the situation
and eventually the cravings will go away
and you will find balance again the next
kind of hunger is sense hunger imagine
this you already had your lunch and
you're supposed to meet a friend over a
cup of coffee when you step into the
cafe all the kicks displayed looks so
yummy and you're convinced that they
would taste good as well out of the
sudden you have more space for more food
so instead of just ordering a cup of
coffee as planned you ended up ordering
a slice of cake to go with your coffee
rather than listening to what your body
needs you're allowing your senses the
sight smell and taste to control you so
if this is you before you make an
impulsive decision the next time just
stop for a moment look at all the
temptations and ask yourself am i hungry
well this slice of cake make me feel
good afterwards if your answer is no I
will only feel regretful and guilty then
step away and you don't need it okay if
however you decide to go ahead with it
and treat yourself instead of scuffing
it down enjoy the cake with all your
senses look smell take small slow bites
to fully appreciate the taste and
texture remember guys eating and
enjoying a slice of cake once in a while
will not lead to weight gain but
scuffing it down and eating mindlessly
on a regular basis may and the final cut
of hunger is environment to hangar so
getting together with the friends and
family over a meal is a great way to
bond and socialize but this can often
lead to overeating the food is there
everyone
eating as long as they continue to eat
you will continue to eat as well or you
might have family members or friends who
tend to encourage you to eat more take
more food you know I omit these cookies
you got to try them or eat more if you
have those kind of family members of
friends you need to learn to say no and
stop when you know you have had enough
food so instead of allowing food to be
the center of a celebration you know
take the time to bond with each other by
playing some group games dance or have a
good conversation so guys for the next
three days I want you to record every
food you eat and then determine what
kind of hunger it was when you
physically hungry where you stressed
bought was it a habit based decision or
did you eat because everybody else was
eating let me know in the comments below
if you want to lose weight and break
your bad eating habits really tune into
yourself listen to your body and start
to eat mindfully if you find this video
to be helpful be sure to like it and
share it with someone who might benefit
from it are the best
you
you